I didn't think we would get to this
point where now you have Putin saying
that it is as tense as it was in the
1980s do you think we are in sort of a I
heard it called the other day not a cold
war but a hot piece yeah that's a good
way to describe it yes a hot piece you
got to love Dana
[Music]
[Applause]
all right Hollywood is shaking in there
reboots Roseanne's new debut had over 18
million viewers almost twice this show
but guess where Roseanne scored the
highest Tulsa Oklahoma that's literally
the middle of America think about it if
TV were archery Roseanne hit the
nation's bullseye how could you have
thought it through yes Roseanne
he talked about jobs Jackie he said he'd
shake things up have you looked at the
news cuz now things are worse not on the
real news
works so Roseanne's a Trumpy her
sister's a resistor but unlike most crap
coming out of Hollywood the show didn't
alienate half the country which is maybe
why it's scored big now we've all got
the family member we'd rather not talk
to when the discussion turns to politics
mine is in a cage I built out of raccoon
bones but in Roseanne's house
disagreement doesn't make you an enemy
now granted Roseanne has done some very
very strange things in her past but
maybe she's trying to make up for it by
creating a show that tries to pull
people together rather than a part and
coming out as pro Trump in Hollywood
that's like coming out as a fish at a
bear sanctuary but that wasn't the only
reboots consider CNN who said stop it
yeah they said enough with foreign
policy and national defense we want to
make over we are now the new Weather
Channel all stormy all the time yes yes
much like Roseanne this reboot hinges on
the appeal of one woman now I don't
blame CNN when things are tough you got
to go with what you know and they know
stormy like the back and front of their
hand but see but CNN at least be honest
about it when your news has gone from
hard to semi-hard
that reboot needs a rebrand luckily we
got a sneak peek of their new lineup at
CNN it is great are you ready for the
most informative news programs on cable
then you'll love CNN's all-new primetime
lineup Eddie it's the breaking news hour
with hose
stormy Dan need tips on the best stocks
then don't miss the market report
with stormy Dan or maybe you're hungry
for the latest on Capitol Hill at ten
it's politics roundup host Ian Stewart
and for you night out at eleven you can
catch the train to handsome town with
Jake Tapper it's the new primetime
lineup of CNN the hottest course that's
not all CNN covers it just feels that
way at times so we covered reboots that
work and reboots that don't now let's
talk about what's incapable of rebooting
I was really struck by how people said
that to me you know mostly people in the
press for whatever reason like oh you
know go away go away and I had a one of
the young people works for me go back
and do a bit of research they never said
that to any man who was not elected yeah
well because none of them called
a state backwards for voting for the
other guy Hillary she just can't reboot
it's like when you get an error message
on your computer so you shut it down and
you think the error message will be gone
now so you power up again and the error
message is still there Hillary for
Democrats you can't reboot her or boot
her but the challenge for the lefty
media is what do you do when the country
is back on its feet but you still want
to report the bad stuff you need people
who will say what you want them to say
even when they don't mean it you need
more than a reboot you need a robot
while his hesitation to say anything to
speak about this truly what's this gene
says just insane earlier today do you
find your favorite anti Trump Talking
Heads too long-winded and boring then
you need the anti-trump pundit 3000 are
highly trained scientist has to every
pundit 3,000 for quality assurance
with just the touch of a button sis
leftist media technology uses simplified
rhetoric to call for 45s impeachment
colluded with Russia he's the agent of a
foreign government he's a clumsy despot
he obstructed justice and funded 3000 is
unafraid to be completely off base he's
mentally unfit he's physically unfit
he's an adulterer well everybody knew
about that one and we're ramping up
production sled every cable TV show that
wants an anti-trump London 3000 can have
one additional features include Spanish
mode and grandfather hard-of-hearing
mode Donald Trump is very bad he's very
bad he's very bad he's very bad sort of
your anti Trump pundit 3000 today
[Applause]
warning this product not effective at
actually impeaching the president
well done practice all this stuff that
the media keeps throwing at us collusion
infidelity dementia his family has died
it's not computing with the citizens
what's really necessary for the press is
a total reboot of the heart if only they
had one let's welcome tonight's guest
she has more sense than a kid's piggy
bank Turning Point USA communications
director Candice Owen
he's produced more hits than Snoop
Dogg's bong Kevin can wait executive
producer Rob law Steve once called
animal control on the Easter Bunny
natural review reporter cat Tim his
dinner plate can pick up all the major
league baseball channels impact wrestler
my massive sidekick pirates bigot what
do you take of the CNN coverage so far
of stormy Daniels is it pertinent or
just pernicious it's just interesting in
my opinion I I don't understand how this
is the new platform I think what you
showed is pretty accurate stormy Daniels
is running CNN's network as well as the
Democratic Party so she's gotten quite
the raise and the promotion yes
could she be in the year the woman 2020
running like for office perhaps she
would have a better shot than Hillary
Clinton did I think he'll see I have a
theory that Hillary and stormy should
run together I think bill would like
that for a bill anyway so Rob you are a
film producer or so you tell people at
bars late at night that's what I said I
you you were but you were there with
Cheers
and and Kevin can wait there was one in
between there or a lot of between it yes
yeah um what is Holly how was Hollywood
taking this Roseanne resurgence are they
learning anything well you know
Hollywood is the place where you learned
the wrong lesson all the time yes right
now what they're doing celebrating I
mean that's a gigantic audience for what
we used to be thought of the deads
format a multicam sitcom yeah she
brought it back she gave ABC a huge lift
but they're all looking around for now I
hope is like more comedies like that
that are relevant I mean look it's wrong
to decide that what made Roseanne
popular is that she's Pro Trump because
the show itself is pretty mixed and
balanced yeah but it's relevant it's
about what people are doing now and it's
especially it's funny it's not quirky
it's not hip it's not clever it's not
snarky just funny she's a funny person
she and her sister argue
in a funny way yeah it's what America
has always wanted in half-hour comedy
that's what all the family was know yeah
it does remind me a bit of all in the
family and and that makes Roseanne
Archie right well right and remember and
all a family was designed to be a show
where Archie learned a lesson about the
progressive modern politics yes Ted it's
everyone watch that show was like
Archie's the hero right now the only guy
with a job he's the guy paid that he
bought the house he fought World War two
he's got to sit there listen to some
shirt hippie tell him that it's okay for
guys to carry a purse
I mean Archie was a hero and even Norman
Lear says it's like when he was watching
and realized that he thought oh I think
I did this wrong yeah I screwed up the
villain became the heroes speaking of
cat do you think this show will heal us
and do you think Hilary will divide us
take that question however you please
okay first of all I hate most things yes
but I could not I couldn't hate Roseanne
I really really loved and I watched the
first episode and I thought it was
really good as for Hilary continuing to
whine about the sexism thing and saying
that nobody ever told a man to go away I
don't think I've ever seen anyone male
or female continue to have nothing to
say and still be up there saying things
yes all it is
all it is is the sexism thing or the
Trump is a mean bully thing or they it's
this reason that I lost it's not my
fault or this reason I lost it's not my
fault this reason those are things you
tell a therapist not a TV camera it's
not it's not true yeah they say that to
every candidate who loses yes it's not
even true they sent it to Mitt Romney
they sent it to Walter Mondale they sent
a Jimmy Carter they sent it to Michael
Dukakis that's what they say yeah the
loser yeah the loser has to go away
Tyrus Greg give me your deepest thoughts
[Laughter]
you know what you in your monologue he's
made a very interesting point another
point you said citizen and that's so
true our president is a citizen so he's
going to make citizen mistakes he'd have
a team of science lawyers and a priest
to cover up his background and things
he's done 1215 years ago and I and I
have the inside information on why he
has not responded about stormy why you
guys want to know yes do you really want
to know yeah because his lawyer had a
nondisclosure agreement but when you
sign it you don't talk about it did you
talk about it you break the agreement
and the sad thing in all this right here
you make the tape date whatever she's
gonna sue her attorney yes thorne he's
gonna sue her attorney because he is
breaking the agreement that she signed
and took funds for so whether he is
wrong or right if the president is wrong
for whatever it was alleged happened
they had agreement his lawyer signed it
he's third party so he didn't have to
sign it and we've been I'm I've done
security we had the same not as supposed
to agreements with clients and stuff she
broke the agreement and her attorney
broke the agreement and the sad thing is
while he's using he's the only one of
the news now right she's in Nashville
doing a strip thing that CNN was
advertising not she's Nashville charging
30 bucks to hear the story by the way
our flight leaves in two hours yeah I
know but the sadness and all this is the
victim again is going to end up being
stormy because she's gonna want to get
hit with the bill for breaking the
disclosure and then her lawyers gonna
hit her with a bill yeah and then
there's Bill Clinton yes he'll be he'll
be hitting on her I have a prediction
that perhaps Hillary is not going away
and she will be running in 2020 because
she has absolutely nothing to lose be a
B except another election which he's
already done and it's better than to
making redundant speeches at 25k a pop
while your husband leaves wads of
Kleenex around the house because because
he has allergies so I think I think
she's gonna keep going I hope she keeps
going I don't like I'm the only one who
loves it I mean I do
she Trump really should put her on
salary at this yes you know there's
reelect campaign but before we all
celebrate I mean I hate to be this guy
at the garden party she didn't lose by
that much I know it's true yeah and he's
not a popular president right lowest
most unpopular president this point is
term mm-hmm but this guy needs is less
of his supporters telling how great he
is and right more tough love and he's
not getting it is a recipe for disaster
November we disaster for his party and
2020s to be very very tough I hate to be
the night here but what y'all talking
how great he is maybe it's better we
give him the spanking that he clearly
likes
I think you know you have allegedly like
allegedly likes I think you're right but
I do think the gun issue is gonna get
people off the sofa when previously they
weren't when you have people talking
about repealing the Second Amendment
that might save him maybe 100 percent